[Music]
thanks to its gruesome imagery and
terrifying tone 1997's event horizon
has attained cult status in the years
since its release
but the behind the scenes story is just
as fascinating as the film
itself so buckle up and let's take a
look back at the untold truth of event
horizon
in the mid 90s paul w s anderson was
still a relatively green director
his debut featured the 1994 action film
shopping was notable mostly for
featuring a young jude law in his first
leading role
unfortunately the british flick hardly
registered a blip with stateside
audiences
but anderson's second film the 1995
video game adaptation mortal kombat
proved to tinseltown brass that he could
make a profitable genre film on a tight
budget
because of this he was given a choice of
projects for his next feature
one of those projects was x-men which
would eventually kick off the modern
superhero genre under the direction of
brian singer
while anderson was offered the
director's chair on x-men he turned it
down
in favor of making the sci-fi horror
flick he does admit that it quote
probably wasn't a good career choice but
he just didn't want to make another
pg-13 film
on the dvd commentary for event horizon
anderson said
i definitely had something dark and
scary in my psyche to get out
so he gravitated toward event horizon
and passed on the opportunity to
introduce the world to the cinematic
version of wolverine and all his mutant
buddies this is the stupidest thing i've
ever heard
event horizon's original screenplay
needed a bit of surgery before going in
front of the cameras
this is because the initial version of
the script was a little too close to
1979's alien
similar to the central plot in ridley
scott's legendary film the crew of
anderson's spaceship was supposed to
encounter something unexpected on their
voyage
alien monsters in the first version of
the screenplay a bunch of evil
extraterrestrials had slaughtered the
vessel's crew
and were hungry for more however
anderson had something a bit more unique
in mind
he wanted to tell a ghost story more
along the lines of the shining
in which the spaceship called the event
horizon gains a
wicked form of sentience and becomes a
crucial character in the film
what are you telling me that this ship
is alive anderson was given free reign
by the studio to reshape the story as he
saw fit
as well as a budget of 60 million
dollars to bring his vision to life
the director basically took a scalpel to
the original script jettisoning the
elements that would have made it little
more than a slightly spookier
alien rip-off in favor of an altogether
more disturbing project
in reworking event horizon to his liking
anderson drew heavily on solaris a 1972
feature from the soviet union based on
the 1961 novel by polish author
stanislaw
lem solaris is a meditative dreamy movie
but it's easy to see the
influence of its plot all over event
horizon
in solaris a psychologist is sent to
examine the crew of a space station
that's been orbiting a planet for
decades
he finds a borderline hostile
uncooperative crew inhabiting a station
that's been dangerously neglected and he
soon comes to find that his friend
a scientist who accompanied the original
crew has killed himself
then he begins to see people roaming the
halls of the station who aren't supposed
to be there
including his late wife more than one
critic including the great roger ebert
recognized the influence of solaris on
event horizon upon its release and
anderson himself has acknowledged as
much
in a 2014 interview with grantland the
director said
i love the movies like solaris the
original solaris
the script for event horizon clearly
draws from that film
those kind of meditative european films
that are unsettling but don't really
play to a modern audience
by adding that kind of visceral thrill
that's making it my own
anderson's solaris influenced tweak to
philip eisner's original screenplay was
diabolically simple
the event horizon designed to travel at
faster than light speeds by breaching
the space-time continuum had traveled
somewhere that it was never meant to go
and in doing so it had become infected
with something evil
while it's never made crystal clear the
implication is that the ship has
literally been to hell and back and
since that basically made the ship
itself the villain of the film it needed
an appropriately
ominous design talking with the ringer
anderson recalled that for the design of
the ship he drew from gothic
architecture and one
iconic site in particular the director
said
using an architectural cam program we
basically built notre dame cathedral in
the computer and then we pulled it apart
and we used
different elements of it to build the
event horizon
so the towers from notre dame became the
engine thruster pods
thanks to the film's beefy budget the
entire interior of the event horizon was
constructed on a cavernous sound stage
and once it was finished anderson knew
he was on the right track
cast members would go i love working
with you paul but i hate coming to work
it was just horrible it was actually the
sets themselves because the crew
couldn't have been nicer but there was a
disturbing vibe
i really felt like we created a very
physical haunted house for the actors to
interact with
however in the end the ominous sets were
the perfect match for the sinister
characters that inhabited them
i am home anderson would need a veteran
of
genre films to effectively shoot his
bizarre sets and he got one in adrian
biddle who worked on such instantly
iconic
films as aliens and the princess bride
biddle
immediately understood what anderson was
going for and with the help of the
director and production designer joseph
bennett he carefully selected a lighting
scheme that would make the event
ship appear appropriately futuristic and
sterile
in cold artificial light and take on a
whole new personality
when bathed in dim light and darkness
anderson recalled his co-workers
contributions in a 2020 chat with
american cinematographer magazine
he said that they spent a lot of time
coming up with a design concept which
they called
techno medieval he went on to say when
the lights are on
everything looks very technological and
very spaceship-like
but when the lights go off and the
haunting begins you start looking at the
shapes and the architecture is actually
very medieval
we extended that techno medieval design
idea into as many aspects of the
pitcher's look as possible
biddle opted to use colored gels to
augment the film's lighting
a time-honored technique that had fallen
out of favor to further heighten the
film's sense of unease
he explained that he used some sepia
brown coming up from the floor to make
viewers uncomfortable on the ship as
well as flashes of red and green
he also said cinematographers generally
shy away from green because it's not
very pleasant but on event horizon i
used
gels to produce that nasty horrible
green you get from fluorescence
i was going for that kind of an effect
to convey the idea that something not
very good is lurking in the ship
at the time event horizon was in
production paramount was
waiting on another film that was running
just a bit over schedule not to mention
over budget
it might seem counterintuitive today but
that film james cameron's titanic which
would become the highest grossing movie
of all time was in no way a sure thing
in fact paramount feared that it might
have a disaster on its hands befitting
the flick's namesake vessel
as such the studio was hungry for a hit
film it could squeeze out in advance of
titanic's debut
according to the ringer it settled on
event horizon which presented a slight
problem for anderson and his crew
the studio shifted production on the
film into overdrive and as a result
anderson was essentially made to shoot
edit and oversee visual effects on the
film on an
insanely tight schedule rather than the
usual 10 weeks allotted for editing he
only ended up with four forcing him to
work non-stop for that entire period
and that's evident in some of event
horizons choppy editing work and rough
line readings
almost certainly the result of anderson
simply not having time to get as many
takes of certain scenes as he would have
liked
against all odds anderson was able to
slap together a cut of the film that was
screened for test audiences and
paramount executives
those execs had seen dailies that had
highlighted the flick sci-fi elements
instead of its disturbing vibe and
graphic violence
but when they got a load of what
anderson had turned in
they along with the test audiences had a
reaction the director hadn't quite
expected
they were in a word disgusted anderson
remembered the first disastrous test
screening on the dvd commentary
you can't underestimate the kind of
shock that this movie had when it was
shown to people
people were really really upset by it
even by the level of unpleasantness
there is in the final cut
and as anderson explained the studio
felt the same way as test audiences
executives were quote freaked out by the
film's grisly gruesome nature
as the director put it paramount is the
studio known for the star trek franchise
and i don't think that this was quite
the space movie that they had
anticipated
just how gruesome was the first cut of
the film we may never know for sure
because so far an extended version of
event horizon has yet to materialize
after its initial disastrous test
screening though anderson cut
over 30 minutes of footage while these
cuts did effectively excise some of the
more graphically unsettling moments
objected to by the executives
they also had the unintended effect of
giving short shrift to the development
of the movie's supporting characters
whose fears and anxieties were explored
in much more unsettling detail than in
the final film
while it's certainly possible that she
may have been overstating matters
slightly
jolie richardson who portrayed
lieutenant stark was creeped out enough
while working on the film
that she's said in recent years that she
believed the production to be cursed
in a chat with den of geek richardson
described how one scene involving her
and sam neil required multiple takes
all of which ended in the same bizarre
fashion during rehearsal
they were meant to be at a console then
there would be a fake explosion and the
actors would throw themselves off their
chairs
richardson went on to say when sam and i
did the scene for real there was the
count of three
and then neither of us remember what
happened next
the explosion went off and we woke up a
few moments later on the floor
that happened every single time during
another scene
she and the ship's captain played by
lawrence fishburne were required to
crawl through a doorway just before a
heavy steel door slammed shut
richardson said that due to his vision
being obscured by smoke a special
effect technician closed the door just a
bit too soon causing her foot to get
stuck in the door
the actress said it was jinxed but we
all managed to have a laugh regardless
anderson's pared down cut of event
horizon was released in august 1997 to
an absolute critical drubbing
even today after having undergone a
significant critical reappraisal it
holds a dismal
28 rating on rotten tomatoes audiences
were also turned off and rather than the
late summer hit that paramount was
expecting the flick turned out to be a
massive flop
grossing a mere 26 million dollars not
even half of its budget
fortunately for paramount the film that
the studio had feared was headed for
disaster
titanic saved the day
of course most cult classics get this
kind of initial reception
and while event horizons flaws are many
it can hardly be denied that it's a film
that sticks in the memory of viewers
in particular neil's unhinged
performance is a thing of wonder and the
design of the doomed ship's interiors
complemented by adrian biddle's expert
camera work
is a remarkable achievement still one
can't help but wonder what the film
might have been had paramount not forced
anderson to work on
an impossible schedule or if that
hellish test screening hadn't gone so
poorly
but who knows perhaps one day anderson
will make a triumphant return to event
horizon
and blow everyone away with a director's
cut here i come
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite cult classics are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you